here we go man here's the story from the
Daily Mail Biden Administration holds
secret talks on stationing American
troops in Gaza after Hamas is defeated
but us officials fear deepening
political Peril after Israel shelled a
refugee camp oh boy there's so much here
uh so it's not a refugee camp here we go
again and uh but we'll get into this
because there are civilian deaths it's
just man is this is it just lies lies
lies but here's here's the worrying part
of the story first Bloomberg I love
their warmongering headline us and
Israel weigh peacekeepers for the Gaza
Strip what does that mean let's just say
it like it is Bloomberg the US wants US
soldiers in Gaza now here's what's
important to understand the way they're
framing it is after Hamas after well
Times of Israel citing the New York
Times says that us special forces are
already deployed into Israel on the
ground to assist with recovering
hostages but come on what does that mean
this means special forces are going to
be working on I mean I I I don't see any
other argument that could be made you I
suppose you could argue the US Special
Forces are just in a in a room somewhere
in Tel Aviv you know giving Intel and
giving advice I don't think we use
special forces for that but maybe the
most likely thing is they are engaged in
recovery which we on this show warned
about several month ago that or not not
even a month a few weeks ago that if us
uh uh citizens are taken captive are
kidnapped then the US typically sends
boots on the ground to bring them back
and so now that we're seeing this let me
put it all together for you what seems
more likely US Special Forces are
already in Gaza engaged in operations
which will result in the removal of
Hamas by which then the US wants to send
more US troops into
Gaza well how's how you guys doing I'm
thinking about Vietnam because I saw
that word Peacekeeper and I remember
they started off the Vietnam uh surge of
troops by calling them advisers so there
was wasn't really a war wasn't even
really considered a military uh
expedition in the 50s I think it was the
late 50s when they started sending their
advisors over there and uh you know just
scaled from there so it kind of tastes
like
that what do you think like oh and I
also think that if there's one if they
get all the hostages out but then
there's one left they'll use that as a
reason to send 10,000 guys in they'll
they just want to conquer the place
they'll just say oh there's still 10
Americans whose identities are being
remained secret uh private because the
you risk of their family and uh got to
send in the troops I mean that's it I
mean the US is is here here's my fear I
hope none of this happens but it seems
like they're doing these things so that
they slowly introduce you into the idea
that there will be troops in Gaza cuz uh
does anybody remember the exact date
when the US announced that they were
declaring war on Syria and sending
troops into Syria yeah most people don't
and I was surprised at one point I
remember hearing about US troops in
Syria and I was like wait what when did
we go into Syria like we're we're in
Syria at first it was like there are no
troops in Syria and then like oh we
actually have bases there now yeah they
started as were just sending them to
help with something it's sort of almost
a humanitarian effort that we sent our
military to take care of and then it
just escalates to being like well we
need to always have a presence there
because without without us what would
they do I mean this is the thing that
bothers me the most about uh the way the
American government leans on its
military which is to say we can send
troops to all kinds of places across the
world but we do not send them to the
border which protects our own citizens
right we got to stop being everything to
everybody or stop trying to be
everything to everybody we can be
everything to everybody here in the US
exactly that's right that's let's let's
do that and you know that's why I'm
saying I see all these like uh there's
like genz videos on Tik Tok where
they're like we should have free
education and free healthare and we're
spending money or the funny thing is you
get this young woman and she's a
communist and she's like Society like
like the the the current generation is
suffering the economy is terrible we're
living paycheck to paycheck when we
could be having free healthcare and free
college and I'm like here we go and then
she goes but instead we're spending it
all in the military industrial complex
then I'm like deal all right I'll take
it if we stop funding blowing up kids in
foreign countries and then we apply
whatever money is is left from that into
like giving Medical Care to people like
deal left you can have that if we if we
all agree to stop doing this maybe
that's their game though the
establishment is like let's let's let's
stress the American people by blowing up
kids as many kids as possible around the
world till they beg us we will give you
authoritarian control if you stop
blowing that is actually a technocratic
tactic they want to give us War
weariness until we'll say please give us
anything but War including putting
people into pods and medicating them
making them eat the bugs I think they'll
just have a taste for it at that point
like but war is so fun we make so much
money off of it we'll continue on yeah
it's back to the FDR right the FDR
Theory right where he goated us into
World War II by um meddling with Japan
because he needed it to satisfy his
promises of the of the New Deal what was
he doing with Japan well they he put
tariffs and and meddled with you know
their trade on steel and it there there
was a lot too it was uh the US is
supplying weapons and resources to
enemies of Japan and to the Allied
Forces into China yeah yeah and so I
mean right over a long enough period of
time if like let's say Hannah clir and
Ian are throwing snowballs at each other
and then I'm I'm making snowballs and
handing him to Ian Hannah Clair is going
to be like dude you're both fighting me
yeah I'll be really mad about it I will
be honest all I do is make snowballs
yeah he's just a guy know just a guy
know yeah right and meanwhile like last
night there there was a a viral clip of
a veteran that was crying uh sitting in
his car talking about the fact that you
know yeah I mean we have we have
veterans here that you know there's an
increasing rise on veteran suicides and
their their mental health and the care
that they receive from the VA it's just
terrible and I saw that video and I'm
like how do we help this guy yeah right
how do we help him and then I'm just
like the problem is how do you help all
of them right you know we we the the I I
I'll tell you I despise the political
Elites the political class so much and
uh a lot of these very wealthy political
uh Dynasty families and I'm not just
talking about like the clintons or
whatever oh there's way more than that
people need to understand they're like
we we know the kennedies we know the
bushes we know the clintons but there
are bureaucrat families there are
mid-level manager type families that
live in these wealthy areas and their
families are all getting in government
and they hate you they use your children
as Canon fod and then what do you get
your sons and daughters coming back to
this country and they're told to go f
themselves left to cry in their cars
because they can't get any medical care
and then they take more of your money
and your labor and they go blow kids
with it yeah I mean I've never seen a
president campaign on I will fix the VA
the VA VA historically has all kinds of
administrative problems but it's just
sort of like oh I love the troops see
you guys when I see you even though we
offer this this Health Care system that
is always fundamentally broken right
I've never heard of a veteran who
doesn't eventually have an issue along
the way and I'm not saying that there
aren't VA doctors VA systems that are
trying their best it's just incredibly
difficult I don't understand why we
don't hear more about uh fixing our own
domestic support systems rather than
constantly saying well we we we've got
to have this presence on the
geopolitical stage like why I'd rather
be present in our own Nation I get when
Ben Shapiro comes out and he says here
is my argument for war like not for war
but like why war is happening we didn't
he's like he's like Israel didn't start
it I I don't know if he says we but uh
Israel didn't start it Hamas starts it
this current round I know there's
generational conflict here but I get it
Ben Shapiro says Israel is Justified in
doing these things for these reasons and
I'm like oh that's really interesting
why is the US involved in this right why
why why who in this country I mean benir
obviously thinks the US needs to be
involved to prevent destabilization of
the region eventually World War III I I
get his arguments I would argue the
inverse I don't know which one is more
likely to happen but the US sending
troops into Gaza sounds like you're
going to get I don't know who the rebels
in Yemen and Iranian backed militias
directly attacking isra Israeli like
territory I mean the US going in maybe
there the the hope is that it will be
such a massive shock to the rest of
these these countries it will stop them
from doing anything if the US is in
Israel they're going to be like we can't
go to war with the US yeah I get that
that feeling of like wow if they finally
take over then it's going to be done we
don't have to worry about it anymore and
that's just not the way it works man
blowback is generational you kill all
those people you'll see their families
and their friends for for tens of
hundreds like what is he was going to do
occupy Gaza for 20 years I mean it's I
joked almost when I said make it the
51st state now I'm seeing things like
they want to colonize they want walking
back completely know it's funny because
the the in the way you phrase making Gaz
of the 51st state everyone's just like
the process there is impossible and then
it was funny because I was like what Ian
are we going to send troops into Gaza
and Spark World War II and now Biden's
like we should send troops into Gaza and
I'm like soly got a call from the Biden
Administration being like more ideas
more ideas well not not to mention the
acute impact right you're you're
stretching America's military thin and
as we're seeing right now there's
probably sleeper cells all over the
country and how are we going to defend
ourselves we can't I mean it's you know
the way I say it is like you know you
can't go to your neighbor's house and
and uh chastise them for a dirty kitchen
when your kitchen's terribly distraught
right and it's not about just the
cleanliness it's about being able to
feed and clothe and everything else that
comes along with having a kitchen I mean
it's a decent analogy but at the end of
the day you know we're not even keeping
our own house clean we're meddling
everywhere else you ever see those
stories about the people on Facebook who
have to monitor like political content
and like Ral violations there's a couple
different versions of the story one is
like people see horrifying murder and
stuff and they're traumatized and they
quit but there was another story where
it's like a couple of them where these
people are working in politics in the
like we got to get rid of fake news and
we got to get rid of you know like rule
breaks people breaking the rules and
they started turning rightwing yeah
because they started seeing these memes
and then they kept seeing them over and
over and over again as they're supposed
to be policing and banning these stories
they end up seeing a whole bunch of
stories and then eventually they're like
Trump's right yeah and so I'm just
hoping that you know like Hezbollah and
Hamas they send in these in Iran they
send these sleeper cells into the United
States 20 years ago and then they're
like they show up and cross the border
and they're like when our time comes the
infidels will pay and now it's like 20
years later and they're morbidly obese
and on Tik Tok and they're going to
Pride parades and stuff and watching
Marvel movies yeah watching Marvel mov
I'm hoping the indoctrination went the
other direction with them and they've
just been like what were we complaining
about this is great I wouldn't be
surprised if that does happen sometimes
and to segue on that um you know I
remember seeing that story
and one of the things that I took away
was that the Facebook uh people that
were monitoring these nasty memes or
whatever they were seeing all this
traumatizing footage they're getting
better Medical Care and mental health
care than our troops right so you're a
veteran of the Air Force like what's the
system what's the status of the VA
what's the problem and what I guess if
you think Solutions I don't know
personally you know um I've never sought
VA benefits after the after the service
I probably could for for certain things
but I just never did I just always felt
like you know there's guys and and women
that were worse off than me so but I do
have some friends that work for the
veterans administration and I can tell
you that you know they they communicated
to me and from veteran friends there was
a pretty distinct difference when Trump
was in office because he broke the
bureaucracy he he actually um created a
mechanism in which the VA doctors could
be held accountable and before it was
kind of like the fouchy thing you know
he can do whatever he want he's he's not
an elected official so on and so forth
and you know Trump came in and changed
that Paradigm and um a lot of veterans
were getting better service but you know
with Biden now now I mean I'm mean he he
reverted everything within days of being
in office do we do we need a private
company that to rival the VA and do it
better I mean I wouldn't argue that you
know I think veterans are pretty simple
we you know we don't want much we just
want Healthcare we want we want the
benefits that we signed up for right and
I don't have all that trauma I can't you
know no ptsc I don't have any of that
but you I have friends that do and um
it's come to the point where they're
they're seeking Care on their own um you
know they're they're doing different
things maybe it's meditation or you know
I don't think that's bad right to have
alternative ways to intervene I just
think the issue is when you know you're
being told we don't know when we can see
you we have crazy delays or programs
where if you come you know you have to
be shipped to a different VA to have
some sort of treatment and then you
don't have the support in that area I
mean it's it's a length it's not that
any medical system in the US is so great
but in this case one of the things that
especially young men in this in in
America are told is if you sign up and
serve you will have this resource for a
long time your family will have this
resource and we know the VA is okay with
offering veterans children's hormones
but they can't always get counselors in
place for veterans who need it for PTSD
treatment I mean the priorities of the
of the VA seem very strange to me and
again I want to believe in good faith
that there are people who are really
trying to do as much as they can and
that the bureaucracy is is holding them
back but it's hard to say we need more
in my opinion more experimental
treatment in the VA like MDMA therapy
and things because the wars that we're
experiencing are experimental Wars with
Al technology like bombs are a new
technology they kill everything in the
vicinity they don't discriminate to see
that would I mean the the brain is not I
don't think the brains are built for
that yet well no I agree right I I love
that scene in the movie Snatch you guys
ever watch that movie with Jason Statham
and who else is in there there's a bunch
of guys it's a guy Richie movie and in
the beginning you got that scene where
Turkish is talking to his buddy and his
buddy's like you shouldn't drink milk
it's out of sync with Evolution and then
he explains that like humans evolve
eating like he's explaining the paleo
diet basically but to to to shift that
to your point Ian humans did not develop
over thousands of years seeing like
dozens of people get limbs blown off all
an instant no I get it War existed and
there was brutal stuff and people being
hit and people dying and there's Gore
and stuff but yeah bombs like regular
old bomb like grenades are out of sync
with Evolution yeah humans witnessing
that stuff is well beyond what humans
you know grew to ever experience I felt
I was walking through New York City one
day and I just felt a demolition uh five
six blocks away the entire Earth Shook
and I still feel it in my gut when I
think about it yeah I had a buddy that
to your point too you know when you come
out of the military you're used to a a
you know a community of of structure and
camaraderie and a lot of these veterans
just want support they just want to have
an outlet that isn't their family so
they're not placing this emotional
burden on them and you know to to some
of these uh um you know holistic
treatment types I have a friend Nick
Nick mson um who's you double Purple
Heart recipient Burnt Over like 90% of
his body I just posted a thing about him
on Twitter today absolute hero and this
guy you know struggled with the VA for
years was terrified to come out of his
home he had so much Trauma from a PTSD
standpoint but the guy found his way and
you know he he's he's doing great today
but you know just the seeing the things
that he had to go through it's just it's
it's horrific if if if the American
public understood some of the things
these veterans are going through and and
in exchange for what they're asking for
I mean this is this is an easy easy
decision I wonder if we should have
maybe like what's a good age 15
sophomore year of high school make make
uh these teens actually watch war
footage real war footage actually ex
watch and see what it's like and then
when it comes time to vote again when
they're older they're going to be like
no no please No let I'm sorry man
the idea that we we got to shelter our
kids from the harsh realities of War
means they grow up completely oblivious
to it and then vote for it cuz they have
no idea but imagine if you if if if
there was a young kid who actually
witnessed something you know like the
challenge is you don't want to you don't
want to break you want to make and you
never know if you're going to make or
break someone with something but there's
too many people who don't understand
what they're voting for when they vote
for war when they celebrate war and
they're volunteering you all to go do it
not them they're going to vote for war
they're not going to go fight it they
want our men and women uniform to go to
go do these things and then when they
come back it's like I forgot about it
well I just read that in uh Ukraine they
were the draft age has been raised again
I think and the average uh Ukrainian
male fighter is 44 43 years old years
old average yeah they're they're they're
pulling they're pulling people off
trains apparently there'll be like a 50
something year old guy in a train and
they'll walk in and grab him like nope
front line and they just send him right
to the front line hand him a gun say
good luck so I'm with you on exposing
people to the horror ahead of time but
then I also still want people to
volunteer for the military because we
need domestic defense and I think I'm
not sure what you think maybe the
balances J yeah but
look do you so I I I used to work at
this office and their hiring practice
was to put up fake ads for what the job
is this is what all these nonprofits do
they call it campaign work they say work
on campaigns to save the forests or
whatever and then what happens is when
when you come in for the interview they
say oh you know you'll be filling out
forms and talking to people about what
you believe and they go okay then you
bring you for another meeting and then
they finally land on you're going to be
asking people for money strangers in the
street and they're like the reason we do
this is because if we tell people what
the job is they won't show up and I'm
like so you think it makes more sense
for me to interview 50 people of which
49 leave instead of just waiting for the
one guy to show up who wants to do the
job and so that that's my view with you
know with with the military in this
regard obviously so you don't want to
shock young people in horrifying ways
but they do need to be aware of what it
really means to be you know uh uh to be
in the armed forces to be a to be combat
infantry and what it means to vote for
it and then perhaps the people who
volunteer are the people who truly
understand what they're signing up for
yeah I mean I feel this would be the
most helpful in high schools in blue
areas right I mean in my personal
experience you know I grew up in
Connecticut Blue State my brother
enlisted in high school to be in the
Marine Corps and his high school bought
him tooth and nail the entire way he was
18 all a senior year so he could he
could be enlisted but they were like no
don't you want to go to college don't
you want to do this thing you have to be
over here you have to do thing they have
no military family members themselves
maybe they're grandfathers but they
there's no actual connection to it and
so there is a a idea that that's for
someone else to do that is some that's
not for me that's not my experience and
again like this is an issue I feel very
strongly about but in addition to the
combat in addition to the the physical
labor that goes being into the military
in addition to the impact it has on in
the family if you choose to get married
and get shipped around the US I mean
it's a really serious sacrifice the
other part is that we don't transition
people out of the military very
effectively so we don't offer career
Counseling in a way that people can
really say this is what I did in the
military this is what it looks like in
the civilian world it's a system that we
both depend on and are willing to send
other people to go fight but when people
are here domestically we don't think
about them I wonder if a lot of the
problems of wokeness and communism and
you know far-left ideology could just be
solved by exposing Young people to the
realities of life I you know when I see
these videos and they're like we should
have free free education and free
healthcare I'm like this person's never
had a job when they're like you know you
know there's more empty houses than
homeless people we could put we could
house and feed every homeless person I'm
like this person's never worked with the
homeless and they've never owned a house
yeah so how you know let's expose young
people to the realities of life and then
have them be like oh I was wrong yeah
yeah and I think there are young people
who grew up and you know the reality is
it's typically
children teenagers that are growing up
in more impoverished more Blue Collar
areas who have to see what their parents
are going through they're living in a
circumstance where they are exposed
earlier it's the and this is not to be
mean to them but it's it's the upper
middle class to wealthy uh teenagers in
America who are in super Progressive
schools especially super Progressive
private schools who then go on to say I
know better than everyone else on the
face of the Earth because I know that
who's oppressed and I know the world
colonizer means that I support that
group I mean it's ridiculous it's very
out of touch but it's not true
universally just it's true in places
with influence I'm a living example of
that you know I grew up in a blue collar
family I grew up in uh you know Toledo
Ohio in the one of the worst the the
worst neighborhood in my district and U
you know my dad worked at uh Toledo Jeep
built cars for a living and um you know
I didn't have a choice when I got out of
the out of out of high school and to
your point you know if I would have
known more about college I would have
started college earlier and nobody was
there to teach me I had you know I'm the
first grandkid to ever graduate from
college oh I hate College college is a
scam oh it is I'm with Randy Marsh on
this one I just watched South Park Panda
verse we watched it earlier today I love
it when they're like college is a scam
and they fire they try to fire a
catapult into it oh it was that I
recommend South Park the panda verse
it's really good it's not just about
wokeness it's about uh the failures of
the economy and they roast the they
roast Communists so so well anyway it's
the color Revolution man but you know
back to what I was saying with with
being blue collar right um you know not
having a choice when I got out of the uh
you know out of high school what path
was I going to take and I had a very
strict really strict father and Military
just became clear as my only choice and
absolutely love the country I've always
been patriotic and you know it seemed
like this was my path at least four
years I could start off somewhere and um
you know growing up watching my dad work
12 16 hour shifts every day coming home
couldn't coach the baseball team you
know things like that you know it it it
really had an impact on me so you know
after the military um you know my dad
and I couldn't sit in the same room and
not agree that these walls are gray you
know but after the service coming home
had a proud dad you know we be became
really good friends and you know the
military you know changed my life but to
your point Tim if I would have known
about certain things at an earlier age I
would have made different life decisions
but yep I think college has become a lot
more of a scam since the internet
because before it was a good place to go
congregate with Geniuses and learn about
data but now it's so
obsolete in my opin maybe for certain
things it's worth going when it became a
money machine
right you know uh the argument I often
would hear from people back in the day
about college is it's where you go to
congregate with other like-minded
individuals and work on ideas and I'm
like but I've been doing that my whole
life yeah and then you look at without
naming any of these individuals there
are certain uh uh people would call them
prodigies you know young people who were
in C in certain Fields succeeding at
early ages but the reality was these
people would go on they online when they
were like 12 or 13 and they were in
physics forums talking with physicists
and then people were like wait a minute
this kid's 15 the person who was helping
us theorize these things as a kid and
they're like oh he's a prodigy it's like
no he was justos in this space and
exposed to it and contributed the guy
who built and developed uh minds.com the
company that I co-founded with Bill
opman his name is Mark Harding he's the
C uh CTO and uh he was 17 when he
started building it but he just learned
it all online he just look copy paste
read the data this means that this means
that and he just I think universities
made sense when they were about getting
people in places to discuss ideas and
Advance you know academic knowledge that
that was great but right now college is
actually just an extension of high
school right I mean it's unusual it's
it's the American University system
where you're having assignments to turn
in every week or stuff like that like
that was not how these institutions were
founded you're supposed to come up with
like a thesis that you work on for four
years and that's all you do and now we
have general education classes and this
that and the other and it's ultimately
all to make money
with especially uh government backed
student loans that they still issue even
though we know it's setting up millions
of students every year for complete
Financial ruin and so ultimately it's
marketing this idea that you will get a
better job you'll have something else
because of this the degree but the
degree doesn't actually make you better
a better thinker it just tells you that
you can comply with the rues set out for
you which I don't personally think is a
value that I would want to instill in
children you know at past certain age
you want young children to learn
obedience and discipline but when you're
reach maturity you should be expanding
your intellectual curiosity and pursuing
your interest and that's not what
happens to the universities anymore so
uh the South Park Pander verse episode
that everyone's been talking about it's
marketed as the characters are replaced
by diverse women so Cartman is a black
woman now but there's there's an a story
and a b story and the B story is that no
one knows how to do anything and so uh
Randy Mar Stan's dad the stove breaks
and he's like I'm going to show you kids
how to fix the stove the stove door so
he calls the handyman and then the
handyman's like well I'm going to have
to come back later you're you know the
the the screws are stripped and he's
like wait I'll pay you more money to
stay and fix it now and he goes ah
someone already paid me more money to go
fix theirs now so what happens is all
the all the handymen end up becoming
billionaires and then when none of the
regular people can get their light bulbs
fixed or their power outlets fixed or
anything fixed they start blaming the
billionaires because the handyman are
all billionaires and then they start
holding up we are the 99% signs they're
saying capitalism has failed they're
like all these billionaires are
withholding their access to this work
and we can't get anything fixed now it's
their fault capitalism's failed us and
I'm just like it's really really funny
because it exemplifies so much of what
the left complains about especially
young people they're just like if they
can't have it right away it's the rich
person's fault yeah it also highlights
the value of artisanry and like before
you were lucky to find someone that knew
how to forge a steel sword you had to
spend time with that person now we're in
a we're in a point in history where it's
all available if you want to become a
plumber you can figure it out but if all
this power goes out you're not going to
you're going to have to find a plumber
to learn or just trial and error maybe
books if you have access to them if
you're lucky and maybe you had one and
there's still a library standing well so
that that was a funny part of the show
is that they basically spoiler alerts I
guess they're just like the real the
real problem was College ry's like if I
didn't spend eight years getting a PhD
in geology I'd not actually fix things
and do work and then I'd be rich and so
they go and start protesting the
colleges it's good it's really good well
like what do you want out of life right
if you want to make a certain amount of
money so you can have a career you like
and then also pursue your interest in
you know start new businesses or travel
or whatever else going to college
doesn't actually make sense you're going
into massive amount of debts you don't
have the guarantee of job you should
look at trades you should look at all
kinds of other things where it takes
less initial investment you're able to
if you have to take it alone pay it off
much faster and then also you have the
option to work in a variety of settings
this is the thing about you know and I I
I got my bachelor's in English I feel
feel comfortable saying this who knows
what I was going to do with that what
does that even mean like what's a
bachelor's in English so the bachelor's
degree is just the like four-year degree
for English it's English literature so I
can tell you a lot about poetry I can
write some interesting essays my second
one I have two degrees the second one
was in communication studies and so you
took basic classes in communication
Theory some like Public Relation stuff
it worked out it's fine if we open a
poetry store do you think it would do
Slam Poet well that was the thing when I
reached the end of my foure degree they
were like would you like to work for
Teach for America I was like I don't
want
though abely I already knew how to talk
beforehand right I could have spent four
years reading the news doing something
else I'm grateful for college you know I
had a good experience because I like I
liked being in class I liked learning
but do I think it's worth the investment
no well see I reject this right this is
one of the arguments I've heard a lot
from people when they're like I think
college was good for me and I'm like you
don't know if it was good for you
because you don't know what you would if
you didn't do it and to be honest the
things that I tell people about college
is that I was really grateful to go to a
different environment I would call in
Texas it's you know more Bible Bell I
was around people very different people
socially and that was interesting that
was that was a a Prof had a profoundly
uh positive impact on my life but it's
not to say that college is the reason I
am where I am today it's just back and
this is this is what a lot I would say
to a lot of people I knew in their you
know mid 20s or whatever they're like I
went to college and I'm doing all right
and I'm like look man I'm not trying to
be a dick to you but you're a shift
supervisor at a Starbucks making $15 an
hour and you're 25 okay there are people
who have started their own businesses by
the time they were 22 I know people who
became managers of fast food restaurants
by the time they were 23 and they're
making you know 40,000 a year so I'm not
trying to be you know it's like you
don't want to be a dick to someone who's
like I think I'm doing all right because
you want to cheer them on but it's like
look man we can't keep encouraging
people to stunt their lives by going to
college instead of learning how to
actually work in ways that can benefit
their fellow men sure especially it's
not the only option and that's the thing
that I think American high schools get
wrong wrong which is that they they use
the statistics of how many people
matriculate to college to say that we
are a really good high school but that's
a bad that's a bad statistic you might
as well say our graduating class is
entering multi-million dollars worth of
debt do you think we are a good high
school that would be a more accurate way
of representing what they think students
can accomplish it's making me think of a
question for you Jr about what knowing
that like the trade how valuable trades
are and the ability to build you you
were project management for energy
companies or at least one in particular
what company First Energy for First
Energy you developed you know you're
saying a campus at one point or you you
designed what made you or what made you
decide to Pivot away from that into
politics well it kind of goes back to
you know where I started so I started in
the Union at the power plants and um the
barrier to management for me was a
degree it was it was a prerequisite in
in the power industry so ended up
finishing my Master's Degree I you know
I was a really hard worker and I caught
the attention of the site vice president
when Davis Bessie nuclear power plant in
Ohio had the reactor head incident and
um you know I I just was a hard work and
and a lot of it comes to what from what
Tim saying right you you apply your hard
work ethic but then you supplement that
with the knowledge that you gain you
know from college I went to college late
in life I I didn't go right after high
school you know that was a service so
you know the pivot for me though to
politics was um coid uh I was traveling
the country 200 something days a year I
was working at different nuclear
reactors across the country and uh Co
had me working out of a home office and
I became politically active because of
Donald Trump uh my dad was a lifelong
Democrat and he was a huge Donald Trump
fan and he talked me into you know
paying more attention to Trump and I did
and um the the long story short is in
2020 um a veterans group and I that I
support um I painted the Trump 2020 logo
on my big big yard in on Lake Erie and
it went viral I was on Fox and Friends
and then I got a call from president
Trump and it it
just it just grew from there and um I
ended up developing a a decent Twitter
following for a guy from Northwest Ohio
and uh when I watched what happened
during the 2020 election and I watched
what was going on in my district you
know 40-year Democratic incumbent doing
nothing for us I decided that I was
going to use the political Capital that
I gained and just shake some trees it
was a democratic plus 12 District I had
no chance in hell to win but luckily
right you know right before the right
after the before the primary election
they redistricted the district flipped
to a republican plus 2.9 and here I am
the candidate I beat two elected
officials State elected officials
absolutely demolished them and I was on
my way to running the general election
so the pivot for me was just becoming
aware of what was going on in American
politics and knowing that I grew up in
poverty I grew up in a struggle and what
I was seeing happening um by these o
archs and these you know wealthy folks
it just it didn't make sense thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 P.M and become a
member over at timcast.net for
uncensored membersonly shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next
time